هذه علامة وردية ، إنها علامة سمور أوراسية
وردية وتعيش عائلتها على
نهر ثعالب الماء في
ديفون وهم من أوائل
القنادس البرية في إنجلترا منذ حوالي 400 عام
تم اصطياد القنادس من أجل
جلودهم ،
ما لم يدركه الناس هو كيف
القنادس المهمون بالنسبة للمناظر الطبيعية ،
فإن السدود التي يبنونها تنظم تدفق المياه
وتزيد من التنوع
البيولوجي ، بل وتقلل من التلوث في القنادس القصيرة ،
وهم ما يُعرف بمهندسي النظام الإيكولوجي.
هناك أزمة تنوع بيولوجي
مستمرة وهذا نوع يمكن أن يساعد في
حل كل من هاتين
المشكلتين يقوم القنادس ببناء السدود والقنوات
لحمايتهم الخاصة ، حيث تقوم السدود برفع
المياه المحيطة
مما يساعدهم على الهروب من الحيوانات
المفترسة كما
يبطئ تدفق المياه ويقلل من الفيضانات.
المصب في موسم
الأمطار والجفاف في موسم الجفاف حيث
تفاقم أزمة المناخ
ويحذر الخبراء من أن مناطق مثل ديفون  من
المتوقع أن تشهد المزيد من الفيضانات ،
لكن دراسة حديثة أجريت على القنادس في إنجلترا
أظهرت أن سدودهم يمكن أن تقلل من
متوسط مياه الفيضانات بما يصل إلى 60 عا
ًا.  ما الذي يمكنك أن تراه صحيحًا هذا هو
السد هناك الذي يمر عبر كل الطريق ،
لذا فهو يبلغ
طوله حوالي 40 مترًا عندما وضعناهم
هنا وبدأنا في رؤية ما فعلوه
بالمجرى المائي
، كان الأمر عميقًا حقًا ، تعلمون أننا أصبحنا جميعًا
فجأة
أكثر من ذلك بكثير  مدركًا لمدى قوة
هذا الحيوان ،
فقد حصلت الثقة على إذن لإطلاق
القنادس في البرية في عام 2015 ،
فقد كان أول ترخيص في إنجلترا
للقيام بذلك وكان التأثير على حوض قضاعة النهر
مثيرًا
[موسيقى]
تم إنشاء هذه البركة بواسطة
القنادس
قاموا ببناء سد صغير أدى إلى
زيادة مستوى المياه في هذه المنطقة
، كما كانت هناك زيادة كبيرة في
التنوع البيولوجي حيث تجذب موطن الأراضي الرطبة
فئران المياه
صباحًا.  phibians وحياة الطيور ولكن القنادس يمكن أن
تسبب
مشكلة لأحدهم ، فهي قنادس كبيرة مثل
العلامة الوردية يمكن أن يصل وزنها إلى 30 كيلوجرامًا
أو 66 رطلاً ،
وهذا كلب كبير جدًا لدينا
صيادون يروون لنا قصصًا
بأنهم كانوا خائفين بعض الشيء أثناء  الصيد
بالقرب من
القنادس يمكنهم أيضًا تدوين الأراضي الزراعية وأكل
أشجار البستان
[موسيقى]
ولكن القنادس عمومًا هي فائدة كبيرة
وتعمل الدول في جميع أنحاء
أوروبا على إعادتها إلى
نطاقها الأصلي ،
ولا أعتقد أن أحدًا منا لا
يدرك تمامًا أهمية  الحيوان
الذي كنا نتحدث
عن فرصة إعادتهم هو حيوان
رائع بالنسبة
لك